streaming how freaked out is Apple Apple
is pretty freaked out you have to
understand something about Apple they
are not a services company they want to
sell devices but the services are a way
to lock you into those devices yeah as a
result as people keep moving over to a
streaming service it removes owning
music as a lock-in it used to be that if
you bought an iPhone you wouldn't switch
to android because where would all do
all your music go yeah with a streaming
service you can switch easily which is
why Apple wants a streaming service I'm
gonna take an editorial comment here and
say that I've always found the
experience with itunes deeply awful I
will agree with you in that assessment
can they get streaming right is there's
something cultural within Apple that is
preventing them from providing you with
a good experience well the history has
not been terribly helpful for Apple in
this case when you think about they had
what itunes music and the cloud and then
there was a music that you owned and
then you could sink it if you wanted and
it just became and then if you didn't
have the right Apple ID as we were
discussing earlier things get very very
confusing for a long time Steve Jobs
have the position people want to own
music it turns out Steve Jobs wanted to
own music most people are perfectly
happy getting a few jobs wanted to own
people's experiences with music that's
right let's dovetail this in with the
emotion to spend Lawson New York Times
thank you to them for your Martinez
today Julien's Auctions a guy bought
this for a couple hundred bucks 30 years
ago this is john lennon's jumbo j16 te
they have matching ones here's the
actual beat this is going to sell for
under a million dollars here they are
where they're matching your the lads
george harrison and john lennon from
another time and place we've gone from
that emotion right to the sterility of
spotify and itunes i would suggest apple
can pay the artists and take over the
business am I wrong Apple has 800
million credit card numbers on file
which gives them a tremendous advantage
but you know right now the way people
are consuming music and people have
written about this already it's song by
song its single by singing oh they know
I don't were Swift so she leaves so she
doesn't go to Spotify she already didn't
go to Spotify so they may try to make
more attractive offers but I think this
actually goes to the heart of what Apple
can do which is one of the things Sam
that we've heard is that Apple is
cutting harder deals with and better
deals with the the
two labels and is pressuring them to
back out of their contracts with Spotify
what's going on there there's been a
little bit of tension there as well
between Apple and the labels because
Apple originally wanted to price their
service at a lower price and the label
said hey wait a second no we are going
to charge the same price as what Spotify
charges in Pandora and others so they're
trying to kind of navigate that
territory very quickly can the new John
Lennon get paid today can they make them
rent they're starving in the East
Village can they make the rent I mean if
they can get themselves a good
endorsement perhaps with a major company
and the tour takes off really well
perhaps they can make even more but
they're not going to do it off digital
know they're OK on the new John Lennon
cannot pay to live in the east vil yes I
was just saying that's wrong yeah that's
true sam grobart is always wonderful